muchos la han calificado como una
luchadora de la voz otros dicen que es
una portadora de luz y de Esperanza para
los hombres y para las mujeres su voz no
solamente reconocida en espacios
artísticos en su país natal ya es
reconocida a nivel internacional por ese
mensaje de amor de conciencia de respeto
de defensa de la vida en todas sus
formas y ha generado discusiones
sociales al más alto nivel es
orgullosamente indígena orgullosamente
maya orgullosamente guatemalteca pero
sobre todo orgullosamente
latinoamericana y orgullosamente canto
autora está con nosotros en la
entrevista de France 24 Sara currics
bienvenida a la entrevista bienvenida
Sara Hola Santiago Muchísimas gracias
por recibirme a ti y a todo el equipo
también de Flash 24 es una alegría
enorme poderles saludar y a todas y
todos quienes nos están viendo y
escuchando también el gusto es nuestro
Sara comienzo preguntándole usted ya es
una figura reconocida internacional la
han visto en escenarios en Europa en
Estados Unidos en América Latina es una
voz en el mundo ya se ha ganado su
espacio que queda de esa Sara que viene
del interior de Guatemala que en las
noches a la luz de una vela hoy a la
guitarra de su papá cantaba con su mamá
con su familia una vida familiar en el
interior de este país centroamericano
que queda de ella bueno es una pregunta
muy bella porque sin duda alguna en el
camino todas las personas también vamos
teniendo nuevas experiencias nuevos
retos pero indudablemente seguimos
manteniendo la misma esencia y la misma
convicción de querer hacer esa música
inicialmente para poder darnos un abrazo
tener un viaje de introspección también
hacia nosotras mismas o en mi caso hacia
mí misma y eso es eso continúa Desde esa
Sara niña que le emocionaba tanto cantar
en ese momento Y actualmente aún quizá
más fuerte y más firme en
también nuestra vivencia como mujer o
como mujer maya kaqchikel en tanto en mi
pueblo en mi país y también en los otros
países y donde los donde la vida me
permita poder caminar Bueno ya está
trayectoria artística en este mundo de
la música le ha permitido ejercer este
activismo social una lucha constante
contra el racismo contra el clasismo Qué
impacto ha tenido su voz qué balance
hace usted de esta de esta lucha social
que usted decidió tomar las riendas es
muy importante Santiago porque yo
considero Y sí y me aferro a la idea y
al sentir de que la música es una acción
también de conciencia social de
conciencia de transformación es una
acción de amor y y el poder compartir
también a través de las canciones esta
importancia del respeto hacia todas las
diversidad comunitaria territorial es
algo que que indudablemente se sigue
manteniendo y ojalá sería maravilloso
que en algún momento así como muchas
otras cantautoras y cantautores dejemos
de de pedir a toda el resto de la
sociedad que nos unamos a las luchas
anti racistas porque llegue un momento
en el que ya no haya más racismo o que
ya no hayan crímenes de Odio que ya no
haya xenofobia por ejemplo eso ese es
uno de los anhelos más grandes que
tenemos pero creo yo que uno uno de los
regalos también más grandes actualmente
es encontrarnos cada vez con más mujeres
más mujeres indígenas haciendo y
compartiendo su voz elevando su palabra
llevando también a los diferentes
lugares a donde van esta importancia de
la memoria la importancia de la defensa
de nuestros derechos porque aquí estamos
todas las mujeres indígenas las en toda
la historia también han estado tantas
abuelas están nuestras ancestras y bueno
esa ha sido uno de los de de los regalos
de que también vamos teniendo es algo
que nos llena a mí me llena de mucha
emoción de crecimiento porque la
articulación va creciendo es una ola
mucho más grande y vamos y ojalá que
ahora en una semana en un año seamos
cada vez más y más y más y que podamos
llevar ese mensaje y que todas las otras
personas que nos logren escuchar también
se puedan unir la románticas van
creciendo poco a poco y se van
extendiendo hablemos de mujer indígena
que es su último trabajo musical también
es parte de una gira internacional muy
exitosa que ya la has llevado por
Estados Unidos España Guatemala por
supuesto Costa Rica chile que le ha
dejado hasta ahora mujer indígena que
trae ahora mujer indígena Guau mujer
indígena me ha permitido conocer y
acercarme a la vivencia a la historia y
a la memoria de muchas comunidades de
muchas mujeres si bien
pues ya como usted lo mencionaba a el
disco me ha llevado a conocer diferentes
países sabemos que muchas de esas
vivencias son muy similares en un
territorio como latinoamérica hay muchas
alegrías que compartimos pero también
hay muchas violencias que nos atraviesan
como mujeres y como mujeres indígenas
Así que mujer indígena algo que ha
traído mucho es un fortalecimiento y un
acuerpamiento entre nosotras como
mujeres indígenas el conocer a nuevas
compañeras artistas que también están
haciendo rap están haciendo cumbia están
haciendo diferentes géneros musicales en
sus comunidades en sus territorios eso
es lo que nos ha dejado también mujer
indígena conocer compartir y para mí
algo fundamental también es que a través
de la música y de cada encuentro no solo
porque no solamente es un concierto sino
que siempre tenemos un encuentro con con
las personas que nos acompañan es que
también nos permitimos el el
sanar claro la música nos permite esto
tiene ese gesto maravilloso de de
invitarnos y de y de sanar no Solo lo
que estamos viviendo sino que lo que
también ha pasado nos permite
abstraernos un poco de la realidad y
desconectarnos y mirar y hacer un poco
de introspección hablemos de ese
cancionero que tiene ahí sobre la mesa
de qué se trata es el cancionero que
contiene que pueden encontrar todos los
que lo adquieran bueno este es el primer
libro cancionero que tenemos y estoy muy
feliz Estoy muy emocionada porque reúne
las canciones de Mi primer disco todo de
mi primer y segundo disco Perdón somos y
mujer indígena ha sido ilustrado por una
mujer aquí en admiro mucho también Maya
quiché que se llama sucely puluc que es
una gran compañera amiga de hermana de
Guatemala
tiene la forma de un cumatzin el
cumatzin para nosotros también es la
representación del tiempo y ustedes
seguramente podrán observarlo en los
códices antiguos en los códices mayas y
pues es una de las maneras también
importantes de hacer una defensa desde
el amor desde la ternura a estas raíces
que también están tan dentro de de
nosotros una mujer indígena y somos está
representado acá y ojalá que les pueda
acompañar también si podemos hacer
envíos a a donde sea el primer paso en
la industria editorial no solamente en
la industria musical sino un primer paso
en la industria editorial yo me salgo un
poco de las preguntas de protocolo de
esta entrevista Sara para preguntarle
por un interés particular Me encantan
los idiomas me encanta aprender la
cultura a través del idioma y nunca
había oído que existiera el idioma
kaqchikel Cómo es el idioma kaqchikel
Cómo se está preservando cómo lo lo
están tratando de proteger de la
desaparición y Y qué particularidades
tiene este idioma Matías chavero manda
bajo una beta más Muchas gracias por
también acercarse a esto tan valioso
todos los idiomas son muy importantes
también para la construcción y de un de
un país diverso para el reconocimiento
también de la multiculturalidad de todos
los países Colombia es un país con
muchos idiomas e indígenas Guatemala
también lo es y bueno cachiquel es el
segundo idioma más hablado de Guatemala
el segundo idioma maya y bueno una de
las particularidades y algo muy hermoso
es que a pesar de que el kaqchikel se
habla en diferentes pueblos de Guatemala
siempre tiene su variante Y eso es lo
que también le hace una riqueza muy muy
muy importante y claramente también el
hablar en nuestros idiomas cantar en
nuestros idiomas y seguirnos expresando
es un abrazo a esta cosmovisión tan
grande ya esa sabiduría ancestral de
nuestros pueblos Pero también es una
forma de una resistencia muy digna es un
es claramente una postura política y
bueno nos aferramos también a esa
palabra porque la palabra tiene esa
fuerza también tan importante es
transgresora es también la memoria de
los pueblos de toda la Tierra de todas
las mujeres de todos los hombres y
cantamos en kaqchikel yo canto en
kaqchikel porque es una forma también de
honrar el latido del de mi pueblo de mi
comunidad es la particularidad de su de
su
forma de cantar es que mezclan los dos
idiomas español y kaqchikel Y eso lo que
ha traído también en parte la atención o
por lo menos el interés del público a
nivel internacional Ya vamos llegando al
final de la entrevista Sara que viene
entonces para el 2023 mujer indígena No
termina en diciembre del 2022 continúa
para el 23 que sigue ahora para dónde
las lleva esta gira bueno feliz
emocionada Ojalá que la vida nos permita
encontrarnos en los diferentes lugares
continuamos el próximo año en Estados
Unidos con la gira luego vamos a Europa
Francia y también España luego por
primera vez va voy a viajar a Sudáfrica
johannesburgo y Esperamos que también
esta música pueda ser una un también de
hermanamiento entre las personas a
quienes no conocemos pero que también
han tenido una sin duda una lucha por la
vida una lucha por los derechos en en
esos territorios y también acompañada de
eso tenemos la presentación de de nuevos
temas de nuevos videoclips y bueno
tenemos pues le ponemos todo el corazón
y le ponemos toda la intención para que
también la música pueda tener sus salas
propias que pueda volar y que pueda
abrazar a todas las personas en todos
los territorios a mí me resulta muy
interesante que llegue a Sudáfrica
entendemos la lucha que tienen allí
diferentes pueblos muy parecidos a los
latinoamericanos como tender esos esos
puentes a través de la música con ellos
porque claramente los idiomas no son
comunes no no hay un entendimiento de
las letras pero cómo la música puede
llegar a impactar a estos pueblos
africanos que tiene usted pensado para
mostrarle a ellos bueno sin duda la
música es un lenguaje de amor y el amor
es algo que nos conecta
indiscutiblemente así que
sabemos que que bueno yo cántico chiquel
y allá es muy seguro que no no vayamos a
encontrar a alguien que hable kaqchikel
sin embargo Pues así como usted ya lo
mencionaba hay muchas cosas y muchas
situaciones que nos atraviesan de una
forma muy similar y la música nos
conecta la música nos permite también
tener este vínculo muy poderoso muy
maravilloso y que transgrede también
esas
políticas de silencio que que el mismo
sistema del miedo o de la opresión Pues
también lo transgrede Así que esperamos
poder encontrar allá seguramente También
tienen un lenguaje desde el idioma
distinto pero también yo espero poder
compartir y entender y adentrarme a la
misma historia y la vivencia de cada una
de ellas tener muchísimos idiomas en
Sudáfrica y le dejó un comentario hay un
idioma que tiene una sílaba que se
pronuncia así
la música que ellos hacen es bastante
particular a lo mejor se los va a cruzar
en su viaje por Sudáfrica Sara y va a
ser una experiencia muy enriquecedora Yo
le agradezco mucho que haya estado con
nosotros en France 24 se nos acaba el
tiempo muy poco tiempo para hablar de
todos estos temas pero le agradezco que
haya estado con nosotros aquí en el
programa y mucha suerte con esta gira en
el 2023 Muchísimas gracias Santiago
querido
Muchas gracias a ti y a todas las
personas quienes nos escuchan Bueno pues
con estas palabras también nos
despedimos de esta misión de la
entrevista de France 24 sigan con
nosotros
[Música]